that's not for me to say that's their
forecasts the chancellor will be
speaking at the end of the month I'm
just not going to get into hypotheticals
okay
um the chancellor is working on that
you're talking about ditching
um home targets for affordable homes why
are you doing that
I'm not aware of any of that uh that
isn't true I'm I'm not that isn't I'm
not aware of that uh policy but uh if
you want to ask Simon Clark about
policies well yes the Deputy Prime
Minister with all due respect has that
Target been scrapped I I'm not aware any
Target's been scrapped
um but I'm gonna go ahead then I'm not
aware any Target that's been scrapped
well it's news to me as well and uh I
suggest that you're the Deputy Prime
Minister you have to have views on these
things I've just been sat here for the
last 10 to 15 minutes you're not
expecting it uh it's a matter a dare I
say for the chancellor I'm sure that you
can follow up with the chancellor today
I'm not aware of there's not something
that's been discussed around I'm not
aware of uh specific things like that no
okay how interesting